what you guys don't know is that's the
car that killed Bruce Wayne's parents
yeah and he got it out of the shop on
that black yeah take it out real cool
right around and the guilt as often as
he could and the license plate says just
chill
well Matt Reeves has unveiled some
Batmobile images here I saw like a tiny
bit on the phone we was like there was
like the collage look and I was like oh
we gotta watch this in full-screen these
are like double reveals aah bats in the
background that's a neat photo yeah
that's awesome you really got that like
yellow tint Nolen lighting going onto
the background to foggy film noir like
deserted Street I love how like the
lights glow yeah the other photos here
oh you got this a ball shot that a
Camaro it looks kind of like a Camaro or
like a recent challenger or something
yeah which is cool it looks almost like
a crunched version of the one from the
animated series you know cuz that one
was very like front long and the rest of
them seem to be you know over the years
they've had a lot of light really big
long trunks and stuff like that or the
tumbler which looks kind of like a
spider or something in this yeah looks
like a muscle car it feels very retro I
like the red look of the tail lights
refracted the red that we saw in that
first look footage of Robert Pattinson
the bat suit plus it suggests his
heroism because you know it's good to
let people know when you're gonna stop
Cassie this photo here whoa that's an
engine the engines in there coming out
the bit this is the engine look like I'm
like I'm actually the engine looks like
bat eyes to me maybe a little bit I can
definitely see that being a bit of the
point of the design there one thing for
sure new rock star is gonna say that
resembles a bathtub looks like a bat
space it does kind of yeah well I'm sure
like they probably designed every angle
of this car to evoke as much of a bat as
they possibly could Plus we've got bat
torso and bat crotch up at the top of
the frame that adds and bat abs yeah I
love that each of these comes with a
sneak peek at a little bit more of the
suit this car looks like it could be in
the Fast and Furious franchise like
that's the thing is like now this could
perfectly open up a window Batman goes
to Miami hooks up with Dominic Toretto I
love this image here where he's just
looking up that's him trying to get his
garage to open yeah yes what's wrong
with the gate we're looking at it going
out for it I get those you say you know
down
what's the gate lock code on my garage
clicker not just once or down I don't
even need to be using the voice in you
move what if this is just Bruce Wayne's
car yeah then they have no people who
doesn't work yeah yeah a giant missile
his old car this looks like a dude would
you I this is a little like a Batmobile
is like a new was driving some cool car
yeah yeah when Thomas Wayne like he got
some inheritance when he turned 16 of
like this was my first car and you can
fix it up Bruce this feels like a hybrid
of a whole bunch of cars it's definitely
a different aesthetic going off of like
what we had with Nolan's Batmobile even
though the lighting Chi reminds me of
the Nolan films the Batmobile there felt
like an army tank yeah and so to Ben
Affleck's BBS one here doesn't look like
it has like any weapons it looks like
this is just for speed looks like a guy
like literally worked on it and like has
a really cool mechanic in his garage
maybe Alfred did design this one
actually I could see that before the
store in LA where Alfred worked with him
to build this this looks like a young
dude put together some sweet car to pick
up some chicks look are always dying for
but also I needed to be functional for
work too if they're gonna ground it and
if they're gonna go more art-deco with a
lot of the style I mean this is not an
Art Deco car no know exactly what time
period this is supposed to take place in
but I do like that it is a little bit
more back to looking like a real car
yeah that's been modified for his
purposes and especially if this is like
an early younger Batman story I think
that suits quite nicely and it's a
slightly different shape because while
like the 60s ones and stuff were based
on you know kind of flashy but very long
they're boat like cars you know this is
an updated version of more of that idea
instead of the more yeah they're
military looking or just fantastical
looking ideas on the taillights section
it does pop out a little bit to resemble
like wings in a way you know yeah it's
definitely got that sort of aerodynamic
you know quality that invokes speed
flight agility well it doesn't look like
the Batmobile bike will pop out of this
one though we can make it happen
transforms maybe no spread wings and
flies yes secret is the Transformers
it's such a subtle touch the wings on
the
on the tail light is so subtle that this
could just that really looks like the
only thing that makes it a Batmobile you
know a lot of people are gonna be making
this out of their own cars but ash sure
but I imagine the the hood of the car
possibly if you look at the contraption
like the square blocks on it it looks
like there probably could be like
arsenal that pops out of there yeah I
mean I first day I thought it would be
some kind of air intake or whatever but
yeah it's like if the hood if all the
powers come from the back I'm sure
there's some kind of artillery or maybe
he's like stored extra bat things in the
front trunk or whatever because you know
that's how all those Lamborghinis work
you got yeah front trunk alright guys
well what do you think of this Batmobile
is this your Batmobile no I got mobile
leave your thoughts down below we'll
keep a lookout for new rock stars video
click the notification bar get notified
when I got video hey check us on patreon
we do weekly Q&A s TV show reaction
stream along just started covering
Doctor Who see you guys soon how much
Gotham Weekly